[Musique]
salue votre nom tv de pouilly 12 singo
qui sont des échecs complets
sauf spécialité la maison disque trouve
l'album trop noir trop bizarre pour les
ricains
je dois me faire connaître je dois me
faire connaître l'abri via juste un gars
chez mercury qui ne déteste pas ton
nouveau disque d'absolument tout son
être
[Musique]
david bowie je présume grenoble mais on
a déjà quelques semaines bien remplies
bank à chicago philadelphie new york et
ensuite elle est mais je crois qu'on
peut se débrouiller pour changer le
monde ça prend une seule personne qui y
croit et il y en a deux deux breaks
j'espère que tu crois en toi je crois
que tu vas devenir la plus grande star
des états unis c'est une station d'aspe
cta blé descente alors pas de folies
parlez moi de votre nouvel album de quoi
il est question sa part des années que
j'ai passées à porter des vêtements fin
mai à m'envoyer en l'air
tu veux vraiment savoir pourquoi ça
marche pas si quelqu'un ose un
questionnement sur ce qui a trait à ton
travail tu lançais numéro 2000 mystique
je n'ai rien d' authentiques mois
il n'y a qu'à la fin et bien soit
quelqu'un d'autre soit simplement
quelqu'un d'autre
je vais pas devenir des membres
je crois que la musique ne pourraient
être retapées un peu
l' écoute moi bien sûr tout tu te
plantes pas
qui est en jeu la mienne également tu
rentres pas avant d'avoir réussi
et par un extra-terrestre tu viens je
prendrai mon cardio et j'en suis fière
une rock star ou quelqu'un qui imite une
rock star
c'est quoi la différence
[Musique]